im rheinland-pfälzischen niedererbach
wird demnächst die oberbacher straße
komplett umgebaut die 300 meter lange
sackgasse soll auf satte sechs meter
verbreitert werden dazu eine neue
kanalisation samt leitungen zahlen
müssen das fast komplett die anwohner
den familien drohen
erschließungsbeiträge bis zu 140000 euro
im westerwald geht die existenzangst um
ich war fix und fertig ich meine das ist
ja eine summe die ist ja des exorbitant
und ich war fassungslos ich bin
fassungslos uns kostet das schlaflose
nächte wir müssen uns vollkommen neu
orientieren in unserer alters
planerische altersabsicherung müssen wir
eine prachtstraße haben muss das so sein
als wenn ihr was weiß ich piraten
abgehalten würden seit über einem halben
jahrhundert sie die ober erbacher straße
so aus mehr straße braucht eigentlich
keiner
aber jetzt hat die gemeinde beschlossen
die sackgasse so richtig schön werden
aber die sechs meter breite fahrbahn
wird auch richtig teuer für die
hauseigentümer denn die zahlen den
löwenanteil der kosten mechthild hummel
muss mit 80.000 euro rechnen
beim ehepaar egenolf sind 36.000 bei
michael paulus 55.000 bei frank bremer
geht es um 40.000 und familie mori
drohen unfassbare 140000 euro
helmut sprenger hat die reißleine
gezogen und sein haus verkauft die höhe
der erschließungsbeiträge hält er für
abenteuerlich zwischenstufen 50 straßen
hab nix mehr im portemonnaie der
bürgermeister aus montabaur verteidigt
das vorgehen damit dass die anwohner ja
schon seit jahren wüssten dass da etwas
auf sie zukommt ich kann die aufregung
verstehen weil es nach 50 jahren
irgendwann trotz der vielen gespräche
trotz der ankündigung für die eigentümer
unkalkulierbar wird wann sie welchen
betrag beiseite gelegt haben müssen das
ist die schwierigkeit
im normalfall der erschließung wird halt
die straße hergestellt dann entsteht der
mehrwert und dann schöpft man ab aber
mit so hohen beiträgen hat hier niemand
gerechnet
das kultstück bundeshaus wird kein cent
mehr wert wenn sie uns ihren autobauern
hinstellen ich sehe im moment keinen
ausweg die immobilie zu verkaufen
das wäre nur mit riesen verlust möglich
die anwohner hoffen dass die
hochtrabenden pläne noch gestoppt oder
wenigstens abgespeckt werden wenn sich
aber nichts ändert rücken hier im
frühjahr 2009 10 die bagger an